[Music]
young wing graduated from yale in the
class of 54
1854 he was the first chinese student to
receive a degree from an american
university
and went on to pioneer a scheme to
educate other chinese
students in the west but it didn't last
long
political mistrust between america and
china brought young wings grand plans to
an end
and the students were summoned home
today's chinese students are
experiencing similar pressures
the top concern for parents in china is
the safety of the student
of their children the covert 19 pandemic
has blocked borders and closed campuses
making it much harder for chinese
students to study in the west
for some universities it could cause
financial ruin
but for the chinese government it's an
[Music]
opportunity
take almost any university in america
australia
and britain and it will most likely have
students from china
lots of them it's a legacy of a bold
decision
taken by the chinese paramount leader in
the late 1970s
to reform and open up communist china
there's a famous conversation where
president jimmy carter who established
full diplomatic relations with china
sent his chief scientific advisor
on a visit to china in 1978 to meet the
paramount leader deng xiaoping
and dung said i want you to speak to
your president right now because i want
to send
5 000 chinese students to study in
america
and so frank press found himself phoning
the white house at
three in the morning and jimmy carter
thought there'd been some absolute
disaster
when he was told that it was donk
xiaoping wanting to send 5 000 students
jimmy carter said tell him to send one
hundred thousand and then went back to
sleep
by sending chinese students to america
deng xiaoping
was taking a gamble dung champion was
not a liberal he didn't want them to
stop thinking that communism was the
right system of government for china
but he was willing to tolerate the risks
that they had be
polluted with western liberal ideas if
they also learned all the things that
have made america so rich
and successful the gamble
paid off knowledge gained in the west
has helped china become the economic
superpower it is today
and the stream of students has risen
from under 5000 in 1985
to over 650 000 in 2018.
the main destinations are
english-speaking countries
britain and australia have seen steady
increases since the 2000s
but the biggest pull is america where
numbers have nearly quadrupled in the
past 10 years
over 360 000 chinese students were
studying here in 2019.
chinese students now make up the biggest
proportion of international students in
the world
hi my name is kitan and this is my third
year
studying a phd in the uk i think
living abroad makes us more open-minded
so open to new things i think
not only i think the things that i can
learn but also the experiences that
i will have talking to people with
different backgrounds
this is a plus on your cv and i think
if i went back to china i think i do
have a competitive advantage
compared to those students who slowly
spend their time in china
for the universities having students
like kitong has been a financial
boon at the university of cambridge
britain's top-ranked university
international students could pay
up to six times more in fees than
students from britain
despite making up five percent of the
student population in britain
chinese students contribute 10 percent
of universities
income from fees in america
some universities are so reliant on
chinese tuition fees
they have insurance policies against
chinese students not coming
and they might be about to claim on
those policies
deteriorating relations between the west
and china
had already made chinese students think
twice about studying abroad
and then the pandemic hit 3 000 members
of this university family
wondering what's next great deal of
concern on campus for our international
students
you know we got very nervous at that
time but we got the stigmatization
towards the chinese community at the
beginning of the pandemic
when the virus got controlled in china
many chinese felt
safer to go back to china now the
chaotic handling of the pandemic
is shaking the confidence that chinese
families once had in western countries
for those still keen to study overseas
it might prove impossible
america has blocked entry to visitors
from china
australia has pretty much closed its
borders
in britain most universities are
confident their campuses will be open
but many overseas students will
quarantine for two weeks after arrival
at the moment the chances are that they
may have to study
online back in china if you're a chinese
family
and you're getting the bill for the
first semester of tuition
and it's online only that bill is going
to be tens of thousands of dollars
that's a lot of money to pay for
something you could get for free
though it's a dilemma for chinese
students it's a potential financial
disaster for some western universities
in britain some forecasts suggest that
there could be as many as 50 percent
fewer new international students
starting their first year
a report by the institute for fiscal
studies a think tank
predicts this could cost british
universities anywhere from 1.4 billion
pounds
to 4.3 billion pounds the chinese
government
has spotted an opportunity they are very
happy to use chinese students as a form
of leverage
so they understand that chinese students
bring a tremendous amount of money
to western campuses and they have been
happy when they've been having a
diplomatic
dispute to use that in april
the australian government annoyed china
by suggesting there should be an
independent inquiry into the origins of
the pandemic
and one of the forms of what looks a lot
like
kind of economic blackmail was suddenly
the chinese authorities saying that they
believed that
australia was a dangerously racist
country and
it wasn't safe for chinese students to
study there
it's not the first time that china has
used its leverage over western
universities to bolster its soft power
chinese officials and students have been
vocal in their criticism of universities
which have discussed
thorny political issues relating to
china
in 2017 chinese officials reportedly
banned
new state-funded scholars from attending
an american university that had hosted
the dalai lama
academics have raised concerns about the
way in which the chinese communist party
exercises control over its students
which they suggest
is often sinister had congressional
hearings in washington
uh at which academics have given
specific examples
of how a chinese grad student in a small
class
in an american campus will say something
critical of the chinese communist party
and the next day
back in mainland china the chinese
police hammer on the door of that
student's parents and say your kid has
been shooting his mouth off
on american campus that can only happen
because another chinese student
reported their classmate
and the pandemic will provide china with
only more opportunities for political
and
ideological control take studying online
many western websites are blocked in
china
a group of british universities has been
testing an internet link provided by
alibaba a chinese tech giant which
allows students to watch british
lectures
and access approved research materials
at their homes in china
the problem with that is that as far as
we can tell
those lectures and that streaming
process will be subject
to chinese law and so if you're a
history professor
and you want to talk about the cultural
evolution and you want to say that mao
you know caused the deaths of tens of
millions of chinese through his
extremist policies
can you say that you certainly can't say
it legally here in china
the repercussions of this are unclear
but the danger
is academics feel pressured to censor
themselves
there are university administrators who
have been much too willing
to sell out their own academic freedoms
and their own values
no amount of foreign student revenue can
be worth
betraying those core values
western universities need to be more
confident in what they have to offer
if the chinese government says you know
we'll stop chinese students
coming to your campuses actually they're
bluffing because
china gains a tremendous amount from
being able to send students overseas
but western universities and governments
also need to make more of an effort to
welcome chinese students
if chinese students were to disappear
from western universities
it would not only be a financial blow
but a geopolitical tragedy
the bond that young wing tried to forge
almost two centuries ago
would be even more fractured
we are more interdependent and better
connected
than we have been before we're trying
something hard
which is to be open to a
china that looks more and more
aggressive
and scarier and more competitive and
more willing to use its kind of economic
leverage
and and in some ways less trustworthy
and so
it's hard to keep your campuses open to
that
china if that china is hard to manage
would it be easier to manage a china
that knew nothing about the west
whose brightest young people had no idea
what a western university was like
and so i think we need to hold our nerve
and be confident that we do
still have something to gain
the trend of chinese students start to
study abroad
will not be stopped anyone who will be
the president
who will be the prime minister will
encourage chinese students to come
because it will be a very valuable
asset in the bilateral relationship
i'm david rennie the economist beijing
bureau chief and chiagwan columnist
you can read more about ever increasing
u.s china tensions
by clicking the link opposite thanks for
watching
you